In a world where no one wants to pay for cable anymore,
a culture will rise where every dumb media company thinks you like them enough
to become a paid subscriber. But until narrative media fails completely.
And we just stare at each other on social media all day, live through Ty.
When there's too much to watch,
the good stuff is hard to find and everything is going to cost you, ah,
progress. Every streaming service.
Remember the company who used to send you DVDs,
that would sit unwatched on your coffee table.
Now they're a streaming service full of shows that will sit on washed in their
own library where the employees and the shows all get asked after two years,
because they're too cheap to give the cast and crew a pay bomb and to flush with
cash, to resist making a new show to boost signups in outer Mongolia. But Hey,
at least they've made some of your favorites resurrected some dead movies,
genres,
and handed some great directors of blank check who cares that they're billions
of dollars in debt when your company name is a verb,
the money printer goes Quickster from the
network that brought you star Trek, the Twilight zone,
and 10,000 shows about crime solving.
Acronyms comes a streaming service that's chock full of exactly that.
Plus a bunch of shows that were designed to sell denture cream,
to viewers who haven't known, how to change the channel on their TV. Since 97,
it's a service who's been so fully ignored by non-Trekkies that their parent
company is already changing the name. Good sign,
too many tracks get ready for NBC Universal's rushed late entry
into the streaming race,
which was supposed to make its big debut with the Tokyo Olympics.
But instead limped out with a socially distance, 30 rock reunion,
special promoting their other shows.
Do you know how many amazing shows I have on peacock alone?
That's a deal breaker ladies still,
if you're looking for classic NBC programs like friends,
Seinfeld an ER,
you also get an sure who already tried this model and it
failed, but did they have a in their name? I think. I mean, not
have copped from the people who brought you.
Everything in your apartment comes the only service in the streaming Wars.
Who's listening to everything you're doing. Alexa, let's chat.
See who brings you edgy acclaimed programming,
an unfathomable amount of absolute crap and free two-day shipping courtesy of a
modern day, feudal peasant, but don't worry.
They're working on turning them into delivery drones,
which are just a Taree gun away from becoming murder drones.
I feel like Bezos is the only one taking the streaming Wars. Literally
Cyberdyne prime love YouTube,
but hate how free it is like Reno nine one, one, but wish there was less of it.
Then come on over to Quimby where you can watch new originals or just wait until
they're ruthlessly mocked on Twitter. Like lady in love with her golden arm.
You've.
Got to take off that prosthetic. No,
I can't take off my golden arm effort.
Third wave feminist six doll road trip.
Sorry.
Liquidy lacks in content and also lacks in anyone willing to pay for this.
There isn't even any joy in this. It's like making fun of a sick dog.
Hope someone takes Quimby out for one last run around the park before it's too
late. You're a good boy Queens. Okay. Maybe not good, but okay.
You're an okay boy.
Seven minutes in method. Hey you, yeah.
You who needs an all new service. We know why we're both here together.
You don't want another new show to watch. You want to watch a show.
Talk about that show. I do. I'm sorry.
Guilty as charged than maybe leave a naughty little comment down below.
Go ahead. Say whatever you want. Does Netflix let you do that?
Because a bunch of Sims, it only boost our engagement metrics.
Now let's get wild and see where the recommended videos take us. Ooh,
a flat earth essay.
You always know what the dumbest worst people are looking for.
America's saddest home videos. Do you like friends?
You better because showing the reruns cost about half a billion dollars.
So give some money to the service that still has all the great HBO shows the
best of adults win and a huge chunk of the criterion collection.
But it's all being subsidized by the Dolors who want to watch this for the 900
time? Are you doing.
It's.
Funny because it's wait.
Why is it funny friends with benefits?
Remember regular TV shows who remembers go green for the service that acts as a
life rat for all the rapidly drowning cable channels,
plus originals that target the women who are going through a lot right now,
demographic with flexible options like paying to just watch Hulu paying,
to watch Hulu without ads paying,
to watch Hulu and live TV or paying to watch who in live TV with premium ad-ons
and okay, we're just back to being cable again. Are we the IC your game?
Hulu Disney minors experience a higher
caliber of programming crafted to meet the precise standards of the company
behind the Thunderbolt to USB dongle,
the lightning to headphone Jack adapter and a thousand dollars steak
featuring storytelling. So refined and exclusive, nobody, you know,
has ever seen or talked about it.
You can't tell me blind Aquaman Viking show and the office where Michael gets me
to, to real,
this has to be part of some kind of elaborate tax game or something.
I pass once upon a time,
a magical company was drunk with power dominating the movie theaters,
cruise lines and the happiest place on earth for kids.
And we're at adults with too much time and money,
but then a play took all the revenue streams away and put all the pressure on
the little streaming service that could,
but with the help of a few great shows of vault full of this Dolger and
literally nothing else of value,
you just might forget to unsubscribe long enough for the MCU stuff to come out.
The Mickey mouse hub, starring these other streaming services.
We didn't have time to mention too spooky for me, crackle still around.
Good for you.
Crackle sports without the actual games gangs without the actual
games, regular STV all over again. Only fans.
What? What's that one? I don't recognize that guys. Sorry.
And yeah, I don't know where you guys are even getting these from.
I've never heard of them personally. That's for sure. Every streaming service
let's just pray. These places never catch on that.
We're all sharing the same account log in.
I'm going to steal the declaration of independence.
Everything is terrible. Your a Peaky blinder now.
So do not be sorry. Be better.
Could my voice be any more dough? Yes, it can.